es könnte alles so wunderbar werden wir
leben immer länger immer fitter sind wir
im alter und könnten den lebensabend
ausgiebig genießen wenn ja wenn das
liebe geld nicht wer
die rente ist natürlich ein thema was
sich unendlich aufschieben lässt was sie
schon immer aufgeschoben wurde und das
passiert seit jahrzehnten die politik
behauptet sicherheit die keine war und
keine sein wird somit schreiben die
rente ist sicher kein anstieg des
renteneintrittsalters und ein stabiles
rentenniveau doch die jungen
beitragszahler ahnen dass ihnen etwas
vorgegaukelt wird dass sie in ein system
einzahlen das ihren ruhestand nicht mehr
finanziert wenig politiker nehmen mal
die challenge an und sagen so ich
erkläre jetzt mal was die phase ist es
wird immer drum herum geredet und
wirklich dahinter steigen tut man nicht
der reihe nach die jungen zahlen für die
alten darauf basiert in deutschland der
generationenvertrag anja und santino
arbeiten in berlin in einer kraft
bierbrauerei an das rentensystem glauben
sie längst nicht mehr aber woran dann
privat ansparen oder einfach länger
arbeiten
wenn ich mit meinen freunden das werden
wir irgendwie brennt oder so versprechen
mit denen wir schon rum dass es bei uns
wahrscheinlich erst ein 75 soweit sein
wird also das kann könnte ich mir gut
vorstellen so wenn ich 1500 verdiener
und allein schon weil sie nicht mehr als
oder die hälfte davon miete zahle waren
und da noch lebensmittel vielleicht noch
ein auto geleast habe wie soll ich da
was zurücklegen stand heute müssen anja
und wann tina bis 67 arbeiten doch klar
ist wenn in den nächsten jahren die
sogenannten baby boomer in rente gehen
droht das system zu kollabieren denn
1992 finanzierten noch 2,7
beitragszahler einen rentner heute sind
es etwa 1,8 und 2050 werden es nur noch
1,3 sein wer rechnen kann weiß dass das
nicht aufgeht
timo thönissen ist hier der chef und
kann eins und eins zusammenzählen nach
jahren in der finanz branche braucht er
jetzt sein eigenes bier als
selbstständiger ist er zwar nicht von
der renten misere betroffen doch als
arbeitgeber zahlt er beiträge für seine
mitarbeiterinnen und sieht die
generationengerechtigkeit in der
schieflage
die aktuellen rentner kann ja auch
nichts dafür dass es so ist sie haben ja
ganz brav ihr ganzes leben lang
eingezahlt und wollen jetzt auch die
rente raus haben und genau so erwartet
das ja auch jeder es ist jetzt keiner
irgendwie schuld außer vielleicht die
regierung diesmal eingeführt hat und
dann alle regierungen danach die es
niemals angepasst haben die neue
regierung ins spiel gleich mehrfach den
großen wurf beim klima der
digitalisierung und ja auch bei der
rente doch als die ampel sondiere
vergangenen freitag erste ergebnisse
präsentieren stellen sie wieder die
drängende frage selbst und haben doch
nur die alte antworten
können wir sicherstellen dass die
bürgerinnen bürger dieses landes sich
darauf verlassen können dass sie eine
sichere und stabile rente haben das
genau haben wir vereinbart dass das für
die nächsten jahre gelingen soll der
kern die rentenkasse soll künftig auch
am kapitalmarkt gewinne machen dazu
wollen die koalitionäre laut sondierungs
papier im jahr 2022 aus haushaltsmitteln
einen kapitalstock von zehn milliarden
euro zu führen
man muss nur sehen dass zehn milliarden
für die deutsche rentenversicherung nach
viel klingt aber nicht viel ist das sind
rentenausgaben für zwölf tage im grunde
und als die rentenversicherung das
letzte mal gute reserven hatte hatte sie
40 milliarden die idee die rentenkasse
am kapitalmarkt agieren zu lassen stammt
von hier schwedens hauptstadt stockholm
sowohl spd als auch fdp und grüne haben
sich hierfür ihre rentenpläne
inspirieren lassen
nämlich beim schwedischen modell vom
gesetzlichen renten beitrag muss jeder
schwede 2,5 prozent als sogenannte
prämien rente in aktien und anleihen
investieren ohne ausnahme die schweden
können dabei zwischen unterschiedlich
riskanten fonds wählen die mehrheit
entscheidet sich für api 7 der vom staat
verwaltet wird
das schwedische system wurde vor 20
jahren dahingehend geändert dass man den
menschen die möglichkeit gibt einen
kleinen teil ihrer rentenbeiträge auch
in risikobehaftete anlagen zu
investieren
wichtig ist dabei dass es sich um einen
kleinen teil der gesamten staatlichen
rente handelt
wir sind beim staatsfonds ap 7 36
mitarbeiter sollen die fast 70
milliarden euro hierzu noch mehr machen
einer von ihnen ist karl friedrich
pollack der fonds hat krisen wie den
elfter september die globale
wirtschaftskrise 2008 und auch die
pandemie überstanden solche turbulenzen
relativieren sich sagt pollak wenn man
über den zeitraum eines ganzen
berufslebens investiert
das wort spekulieren muss man in einer
zeitlichen perspektive betrachten wenn
man kurzfristig in aktien investiert
dann ist das in der tat spekulativ aber
je länger ihre zeitliche perspektive ist
desto länger ist der zeitraum
investitionen und desto weniger
spekulative dass
die fdp wollte deutschland in richtung
schweden führen doch mehr als zehn
milliarden euro konnte christian lindner
bei den partnern dafür nicht locker
machen
sie hatten den plan diese skandinavische
vorbild bei der rente zu folgen das also
teile der rentenbeiträge an den
kapitalmarkt gehen sind sie damit
zufrieden
es gelingt jetzt ein einstieg in eine
teilweise
kapitaldeckung der gesetzlichen rente
ich jedenfalls sehr dass das für
sozialdemokraten und grüne ein sehr
weitgehender schritt war ein schritt den
die unionsparteien in den vergangenen
jahren selbst nie vermocht haben zu
gehen
doch spd und grüne haben die idee
kassiert dass jeder einen teil seiner
beiträge in aktien anlegen muss was von
schweden übrig bleibt ist eine
zusatzrente freiwillig weil mit
abwahlmöglichkeit und das auch nur zur
prüfung so steht's im sondierungs papier
wir werden dazu das angebot eines
öffentlich verantworteten fonds mit
einem effektiven und kostengünstigen
angebot mit abwahlmöglichkeit prüfen
als zusatzangebot ist die frage wer kann
sich das denn eigentlich leisten oder
wem kann man zb zwei zusätzliche
beitragspunkte noch abverlangen höher
verdienen dann kann man das vielleicht
aber bei niedrigverdienern schafft das
einfach engpässe diese ohne weiteres gar
nicht mehr zu lösen sind olaf scholz
hatte im wahlkampf versprochen die
renten bleiben stabil das eintrittsalter
unangetastet mit dem was bisher
verhandelt wurde ist langfristig gar
nichts gelöst
[Applaus]
also es wird nicht gehen ohne dass das
rentenzugangsalter angehoben wird die
lebenserwartung steigt ja das ist
erfreulich aber ganz ohne geht es nicht
zurück zur jugend nach einer umfrage
sehen sich drei viertel der deutschen
beitragszahler außerstande bis zum 67
lebensjahr zu arbeiten geschweige denn
länger eine antwort wie das rentensystem
finanziert werden soll die droht auch
die neue regierung dem volk schuldig zu
bleiben